la terre
un joyau vieux de 4,5 milliards d'années
qui abrite aujourd'hui cette dame 5
milliards d'êtres humains
les raz-de-marée d'une violence inouïe
ont balayé les côtes
mais qu'avons nous fait pour en arriver
là
entre catastrophes naturelles et
vaches intensif surpopulation notre
planète a atteint ses limites
la planète est en train de devenir une
étude la moitié de la population
actuelle à mourir dans les 15 ou 20 ans
on est en train de perdre la bataille
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous devons
agir
après la diffusion de son documentaire
événement legacy hier soir sur m6 ce
soir yann arthus bertrand en train de
nous répondre en direct à cette question
notre planète est elle condamnée
là on a une grosse rassemble on a pris
dans la gueule va pas se mentir on ne
saurait yann arthus bertrand est avec
nous et merci d'être avec nous je très
heureux de vous recevoir comme à chaque
fois et c'est vrai que hier j'ai vu les
commentaires passés sur les réseaux
sociaux incroyable j'ai dû le voir après
en replay parce que j'étais voilà
j'étais sur une émission comme
d'habitude que je passe plus de temps
sur les plateaux télé qu'ils mangent
chez moi en train de regarder les séries
en tout cas il y avait des moments très
très fort hier mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
un mois tous les messages que je voyais
c'était c'est magnifique
il faut regarder mais ça fait vraiment
quand même très très peur c'était une
alerte aussi et que vous vouliez faire
simplement je voulais dire qu'on regarde
tous ensemble la vérité en face qu en
train de se passer mais je suis qu'un le
messager de ce que nous disent les
scientifiques savaient 50 ans que je
m'intéresse à l'environnement et à
l'écologie à l'écologie disons à la vie
autour de moi et ce que je vois
aujourd'hui bout de cinquante ans c'est
incroyable quand j'étudiais les lions il
ya 40 ans au kenya jamais je réponds
c'est que tous les animaux que gl que le
travail et les girafes les hippopotames
serait aujourd'hui sur la liste rouge
des éléments voie de disparition les
lions qui étaient 400 mille cent vingt
mille aujourd'hui et je pensais pas que
l'espèce la plus en danger
ça serait la mienne ouais passerai mes
petits-enfants et c'est ça c'est quelque
chose de fort dans ce film on a essayé
de parler avec gravité si c'est en train
de se passer
voilà alors c'est un financier vous
mettez en garde contre la surpopulation
aussi de la terre mais nous a donné des
chiffres qui sont regardés ça quand
j'étais enfant
nous étions à peine plus de deux
milliards et demi en l'espace de ma vie
seulement nous sommes trois fois plus
nombreux le temps de voir ce film où
seront vingt mille de plus sur la
planète en quatre jours seulement nous
serons à millions de plus nous faisons
de plus en plus lourdement sur la terre
notre empreinte de plus en plus profonde
à mesure que nous nous encombrent on
d'objets aujourd'hui la planète n'est
pas confronté à une crise
environnementale majeure mais à 2 la
crise climatique et celle de la
biodiversité
je veux dire c'était vraiment un
chef-d'oeuvre moi j'ai jamais vu un
documentaire comme ça vous avez cassé
les codes du documentaire ya pas de très
peu d'interviews très peu d'êtres
humains etc beaucoup de paysages et avec
ça vous réussissez raconter une histoire
en plus et à faire passer des messages
et ça a cartonné en audience donc bravo
merci beaucoup
il faut le voir en replay fait que
formidable c'est qu'on peut le revoir
alors que le film le film a également
évoqué un autre sujet majeur la
pollution du plastique ça on en parle
beaucoup et vous avez montré des images
qui sont révélatrices d'un très très
gros problème regarde et regarde depuis
1982 j'avais 35 ans nous avons doublé
l'extraction des ressources naturelles
arrachée à la terre
et nous balançons amer plus de 8
millions de tonnes de plastique tous les
ans
l'équivalent d'un camion poubelles
déversées dans la mer à chaque minute
qui passe ce matériau peut mettre des
siècles à se dégrader et en attendant il
remplit le ventre des rivières des
poissons et des oiseaux
ces images sont pour moi invraisemblable
inregardable c'est tout un symbole nous
sommes dans une civilisation de déchets
oui delphine en fait l'homme est
intelligent il a cette intelligence donc
s'il y avait sept milliards de personnes
intelligentes ce serait pas le problème
déjà nous pouvons nous engager mis de
côté les gens ne sont grasses et éco
citoyen aujourd'hui encore des gens qui
jettent leur chewing gum par terre leurs
mégots par terre qui se coupe pas qu'ils
coupent pas le
quand il brosse les dents c'est qu'on
soit 7 milliards et demi le problème des
grades arthus bertrand qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça là on est là on est
heureux c'est fini ce sas et c'est bien
ce que vous dites et je vais pas le
critiquer mais par rapport à l'énormité
ce que devant nous on est prisonnier de
cette religion cette tyrannie de la
croissance et le pétrole c'est notre
croissance
aujourd'hui imaginer que écoutez bien ce
à 10% de la population mondiale et mais
70% du co2 10% et responsables de 70%
des réchauffements climatiques
c'est 10 % c'est toi c'est moi alors
tous ici et se finit pas contre les
politiques qui n'est pas contrôlée le b
il est contre moi est ce que moi je suis
capable de changer ma façon de vivre
en voilà l'homme politique desquels
reflet parce que nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui les lobbys personnes
m'obligent à mettre de l'essence dans ma
bagnole personnes mobiles de mieux
consommer la viande industrielle c'est
moi de décider
et aujourd'hui la situation est
tellement grave que nous permet à chacun
de donner du sens à notre vie telle
qu'elle songe de l'amérique à quoi je
sers qu'est-ce que je peux faire et si
on peut tous se poser la question
il ya une grosse urgences alors ya votre
livre aussi cap 2030 une décennie pour
changer le monde on va revoir d'autres
images
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on a
encore une chance de sauver la planète
ou d'abord une décennie pour changer le
monde mais de sauver la planète il a
continué à tourner
le sauver la vie telle qu'elle est
certes il y à 5/5 cinq extinctions sur
la terre de la vie sur terre
on parle de la sixième extinction dur à
l'homme moi je me pose pas la question
si on va y arriver ou pas c'est mon
devoir c'est ma mission de le faire
c'est tout ce temps de mission ici sur
le plateau est d'essayer de prix
meilleur pour nous en avons tout ce
qu'on voit avec tout ce qu'on voit et on
voit que mine de rien il ya peu de
choses qui sont faites et c'est très peu
pris au sérieux
est ce que vous pensez franchement yann
arthus-bertrand qu'on va réussir à
endiguer ces sept 7 c est ce que toi là
le prends au sérieux
c'est ce qui m'intéresse moi la base y
engage toi fais longtemps l'homme
présentait émission bazille c'est tout
ce ton boulot on a chacun a un rôle à
jouer ici a dit qu'elles régissent le
boulanger étoiles mais le premier jeu
c'est yann arthus bertrand et je sais
combien de mai est juste ce que la
france à l'échelle de la france
est ce qu'on peut faire changer alors
est-ce qu'on a un poids assez fort et je
dire ce livre là 150 français choisis au
hasard pas écolo qui connaissent rien
ils ont sept week-end on les brief à la
fin ils deviennent plus radical que moi
quand tu vois le gars qui vit en
province qui débattent on va rouler on
va mettre la limitation de la voiture
d'à voiture 110 km/heure sur notre route
nous à paris on s'en fout un peu
mes gars qui lie en province il prend
les bugs tour où tous les jours il est
capable de faire cet effort de décidé de
rouler à 110 km heure je veux dire c'est
quand on sait ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que dans la petite gare
était allé là quand on cesse quand
j'irai passer on ne peut pas revenir en
arrière
le le temps qu'ils avaient avant faut
faire le deuil de l'époque était
aujourd'hui on va vers un changement
climatique majeur et notre devoir c'est
de me battre tous
peut-être qu'on n'arrivera pas mais on
va essayer c'est un devoir mais tes
enfants ils diront quoi il dit on mais
mon père il le savait il a rien fait ah
ben ben ils le savaient qu est ce qu ils
ont été courageux ils ont essayé de
changer
bien sûr c'est difficile c'est un et
nous on est le pays riches nous ont bien
sûr on pleure on peut vivre mieux avec
moins mais quand un pays en voie de
développement que t'as pas d'éducation
il n'y a pas de démocratie il n'y a pas
de travail et pas de santé
c'est difficile alors dire de décarbonés
notre vie même nous on peut le faire
encore aujourd'hui et on doit le faire
c'est notre mission à tous non mais
c'était un peu c'est important moi
j'aime parce que j'aime la façon de
parler de serre tuées par balles on
comprend ce qui vient large trouve que
voilà vraiment utile ou tu nous
sensibilise tout cela tu sensibilise
certaine
tous les jeunes et les moins jeunes qui
nous regardent ce soir à 19h57 on dirait
qu'ils se disent mais ils se disent tous
est-ce qu'on a une chance et qu'est ce
qui va se passer en fait moi je pense
yann arthus bertrand c'est ce qu'on a vu
hier mais je pense qu'il faut dire aux
gens si on bouge pas qu'est ce qu'il va
se passer dans l'est dans l'etna dans
les prochaines années à venir on voit
qu'il ya des choses qui se passent dans
des pays et des shows ddd condédé des
conditions climatiques des phénomènes
climatiques qu'on voyait pas avant et on
a l'impression que ça se dégrade de plus
en plus vives louis qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans les quatre cinq ans à venir
bon je pense que turlock moi non mais ce
que je sais c'est que le secrétaire
général des nations unies s'est pas
c'est pas le patron de greenpeace un
scellé secrétaire général de la coi il
dit qu'on va vers une catastrophe
climatique fulminante
il faut savoir que le climat qu'on a eu
pendant vingt mille ans il est parti à
jamais il ne reviendra pas le climat
qu'on a vu il faut le savoir mais va
falloir qu'on apprenne à s'entraider à
blick d'une façon différente
peut-être avoir une beaucoup plus de
bienveillance pour la vie autour de nous
est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
regarder ce qui est vivant autour de
nous de notre façon alors moi évidemment
votre documentaire je les trouvais
absolument magistral je trouve à la fois
poétique lyrique c'est pour moi une
déclaration d'amour à la planète
mais pour autant sur le fond le côté la
surpopulation puisqu'on montrent bien
que des années 1960 et en et 2 milliards
et là on est à 7 5 milliards même un peu
plus comment on fait en fait on trie
l'ins et la politique de l'enfant unique
que comment on va faire par exemple
parce que vraiment vous parler de
l'avion dont l'avion ok bon il ya une
sorte de tourisme de masse au tout le
monde a pu aller où peut aller à l'autre
bout du monde avant la pandémie est une
couleur mais alors comment on fait on
trie alors on va dire non alors les
jours ici ils peuvent prendre l'avion
parce qu'on va augmenter les tarifs
et puis les gens pauvres dont ils n'ont
plus le droit voyez ce que je veux dire
en fait c'est fait mais j'ai pas la
personne liée à la production on peut
tous aujourd'hui prendre l'avion
seulement si c'est essentiel pas le fond
avant peser un week end à marrakech
en tout on a tous fait ça on pourra plus
le faire aujourd'hui
je pense que j'ai pas la solution je
n'ai pas la solution mais on est bien
évidemment il faudrait une espèce de
gouvernement mondial a concédé ce qu'on
s'entende
si la france tout seul décarboniser côté
on fait pas notre commerce
notre balance commerciale va s'écrouler
ça l'homme politique il a été il est élu
pourquoi pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat et les emplois donc décarbonés
le pays c'est prendre des risques mais
vous faut être courageux dire la vérité
mais je vais vous dire ce qui va changer
quand on sera aujourd'hui quand il ya la
marche pour le climat à paris on est 50
milles dans la rue l'autre jour on sera
3 4 millions manifester
l'arrivée comme pour l'arrivée la coupe
du monde de choses changeront mais
politique ce n'est que le miroir si on a
envie de changer tous ensemble on
changera c'est vous en parler tous les
jours
si vous c'est dans votre vie c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est ça qu'il
faut savoir c'est faux oui j'ai quand
même d'une émission l'émission vous et
tendances de vous moquer un petit peu de
tout mais ça on peut pas se moquer de la
vie de nos enfants et nos petits-enfants
peut pas le faire on n'a pas le droit de
le faire mais je suis d'accord avec vous
mais alors pourquoi vous engagez pas en
politique parce que je ne serais ce que
je faisais le giron politique je pense
que je fais c'est bien plus qu'un
ça c'est un vrai débat politique que
j'amène ont fait réfléchir des français
je pense que ce film là qu'on affecte
mon équipe
comme tous les écolos hulot n'a pas été
capable de faire la peau les terrils est
bienvenue mais moi je suis pas plus
capable que mais chacun son boulot et je
pense que les hommes politiques
j'imagine le savez il ose qui raconte
quand il a fait 2000 réunion connaît
2010 qui prenait des décisions qui
recevait des appels de partout
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est un
autre métier moi je fais pas ce métier
là j'ai moi j'ai envie d'être résolument
optimiste grâce à des gens comme vous
yann arthus bertrand
aujourd'hui nos enfants et sont
sensibilisés c'est vraiment ma fille si
jamais j'ai un paquet par talent me dit
tu leur as marre je le met à la poubelle
à l'école ils apprennent la l'importance
de la planète
donc je pense que bien entendu votre
documentaire il est extraordinaire mais
aujourd'hui nos enfants vous leur
adresser un message dans la la fin
notamment les enfants
ils ont réagi sont là ils vont sauver la
planète mais j'ai envie d'y croire
vraiment il ya un mois qui sauve la
planète j'y crois moi c'est très bien il
ramasse des papiers par terre en même
temps il passe dix sept heures par jour
sur une tablette qui dégage du co2 de
façon invraisemblable
donc moi je suis pas aussi optimiste que
toi sur ce plan là et alors il ya un
truc que vous dites à la fin en quelques
secondes
et pourtant c'est importantissime par
rapport à ce qu'on vit actuellement
c'est à force de déforester et tout est
bien il ya de moins en moins de distance
entre les animaux et qui sont très
malheureux et nous la virus
on se les communique beaucoup avant
c'est un problème fondamental aussi
nicolas
non moi c'est moi ce qui me gêne c'est
que j'ai l'impression qu'on nous
culpabilise de plus en plus et de
l'autre côté vous dites que qu'on est
tous responsables mais au quotidien
donnez moi par exemple cinq choses qu'on
devrait changer donc les téléspectateurs
comprennent parce que effectivement la
prise de conscience vous souvenez avec
rom qui a fait plus de
millions de téléspectateurs à l'époque
sur france 2 là les audiences soient un
petit peu moins importante et je crois
savoir pourquoi c'est parce que en fait
on nous culpabilise surtout en ce moment
et de l'autre côté on vois pas ce qu'on
peut changer au quotidien chacun de
notre côté parce que quand les delphine
de son exemple effectivement on de pas
eu de par exemple ne pas gâcher par
exemple l'eau des choses comme ça c'est
des choses qu'on peut faire également il
alors moi je vais te d'aidé pour ce film
j'ai beaucoup de mal à le vendre
personne ne voulait le prendre parce que
c'était trop pessimiste
aujourd'hui de dire la vérité c'est
d'être pessimiste d'accord mais ouais on
va tous mourir un jour faut le savoir
on peut raconter ce que je suis que le
messager de ce que disent les
scientifiques
simplement j'ai alors voulu vous donner
un exemple allez-y arrêter de consommer
les viandes industrielles extrêmement
simple tous les coachs sont des millions
de cochons qu'on ait enfin vincent des
gens qui n'ont pas les moyens de
s'acheter arrêter avec ça non non non il
y attendait non mais qui nous dit c'est
possible usage de vos regarde quand il
est d'accord mais bon il ya des gens qui
peuvent pas médecin qui peuvent
ok donc c'est cet argent qui carbure à
l'essaie plus cher à cendres et prier
des paysans qui suit c'est tous les
jours parce qu'on paye le lait pas son
prix qu'on n'achète pas la guerre est ce
que c'est normal c'est une honte que les
paysans ne peut pas vivre ce qu'ils font
un bon boulot il faut les aider
autre chose j'ai arrêté après prendre
l'avion veut voter pour les politiques
qui mettent l'écologie au coeur de leur
programme mais pas les écouterai alors
on va parce qu'ils ont confiance dans
les gens qui nous dirigent c'est
important c'est quelque chose sinon
alors au lez lille est vraiment les
choses à faire l'association devenir
bénévole pour aider les gens croire
qu'on peut aimer qu'on peut partager
avec plus de bienveillance regarder le
monde de nous sans cynisme et sans voilà
sans scepticisme en permanence croire
aux bonnes choses aujourd'hui il ya en
vidant un mois extrêmement méchant mais
quand on fait quelque chose on savait
tout sur vous et vous et bien sûr les
réseaux que ça se passe
chacun peut trouver ou est ce qu'il peut
faire quelque chose c'est quand même pas
très difficile de réfléchir comment
dépenser moins de carbone voilà merci en
tout cas
yann arthus-bertrand cap 2030 une
décennie pour changer le monde
vous venez nous voir quand vous voulez
yann arthus-bertrand si vous avez un
message à faire passer parce que j'ai
joué avec plaisir et tu sais que si tu
as besoin que jova se passer des
messages tout abonnement et jeudi seront
également replay
et si tu veux que je fasse un petit
message tous les soirs takam l'écrire
par sms tu l'envoies et je le dirai
jamais fait ça non en fait ça allait mal
c'est quoi tous les soirs je démarrerai
l'émission par un petit message sur as
effet à chauny alors on doit y aller la
seule énergie durable c'est l'amour
merci c'est qu'on passe et chic va voir
une femme pour défendre ses enfants
ouais ça c'est l'énergie de l'amour une
femme va pas capable de mettre sa vie en
danger
et est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire la même chose pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants pour la vie que tour de
nous séparer passé difficile on regarde
le sondage
oui à 75% et non à face à ces choses qui
font pleurer moi ça voilà jean que des
jeunes dans les enfants aujourd'hui
pense que maintenant on peut tous se
battait pour y croire ça va être
difficile mais on a fait
on